and use kiss number two is to use the
bigquery for signature based search
based on the result is that from the
Decatur model you trained with machine
learning engine we use the ml engine for
extracting the feature vectors so I'd
like to show another demonstration of
bigquery smart so if you go to click
smart
you have the another demonstration
called image search and you can choose
one of the key images let me drive is
the elephant so we will be using this
elephant image as a key image and
compared 1 million images with this key
image to find these similar images on
bigquery regarded and the query has
processed 8.8 a give it data over the 1
million images in 10 seconds and all you
see is the similar images and you may
notice that you always also have the
images that is not elephant like this
this is not an elephant but still it
looks the same looks similar to the
neural networks and this is a
operatory is not an animal it's a statue
but still the neural network thinks it
must be similar thing this is not an
elephant but it has the same kind of the
texture or patterns so the neural
network thinks they are similar so this
is not a keyword search or pattern
matching but they're comparing the old
feature villages or signatures of images
so you can get the much smarter search
on the bigquery so how did
this of course we have imported audio a
million images from Wikimedia on the
Google Cloud storage and then we have
used machine learning engine mm engine
to learn the convolutional neural
networks on the ML engine this is a
typical neural network design used to
body analyzing the images but usually
people are using CNN to get the latest
or the images such as is it a cat with a
human face is it flower but instead of
the getting labels we are using CNN to
extract the feature vectors that could
be in signatures of the old images and
by using the bigquery and ugf you can do
the similar research against images and
we have we have used vgg 16 cities and
population and design and we are
extracting the feature vectors from the
final fully connectional layers